like I have to look I have to bring this
up because we were both at the Christmas
tree lighting I was most excited like
they were like will you host the show I
was like sure yeah I love it like I love
Christmas I was most
excited this is me dancing singing every
damn word I'm not kidding I wore my
sister out with your song at
Thanksgiving like it came out in October
and I was I literally told my I was like
please get her on the show I was like I
this is the DJ played Christmas song I'm
gonna say it fight me on it it's the
greatest Christmas song to come out
since all I want for Christmas is you
it it's the greatest contemporary
Christmas song to come out like I I love
it so much it makes me so happy I'm I'm
not kidding I have sent videos to my
friends like Blake Shelton and Nile
theyve I've hit them up so much with
videos of me just singing your song good
yeah it's so good but you know what
that's what I wanted that's the reason I
never made a Christmas album before was
cuz I couldn't find in my mind I
couldn't find a way to put myself into
to a share Christmas you know so then I
found these I found my a girl I've known
since I she was four years old sent me
that song and and um and I didn't even
know it was her Sarah Hudson four years
old Sarah Hudson big writer whatever
yeah so I got that and then all of a
sudden I started to kind of not you know
how your mind is thinking but you're not
aware of it
but so then I thought about doing the
song with Darlene oh I did not know the
backstory on that that you originally
did I didn't know that I love that you
sing the backgrounds and then y'all
Twisted it and now she's singing it with
you no and I because I wasn't going to
do it unless she wanted to sing it with
me because somehow it just wouldn't have
been right but on this one of the songs
on my album Darlene Love who sings baby
please come home and everybody knows it
blah blah blah blah when I was 17 I did
the background on it so when we came
together with it I never knew that
really it it was really good I never
knew that I think I heard you say that
I'm Fallon and I was like I never knew
that I think that's incredible no but
how would you know this like nameless
faceless little kid get in the back Shar
could you just step back Shar could you
just step back Shar could you just sing
a little softer no but that oh that's
been my thing the whole life they're
like you're too loud blend you're
excited but I I have to say this too
because I think this is incredible and I
don't know any other artist that has
accomplished this but this is another
number one for you and you have number
one spanning seven
decades
like no one will accomplish that two of
us have who are you gonna say a band
don't say a band it's a band it doesn't
count took four of them to be one of
me that's ni my
favorite exactly Rolling Stones in me
that's incredible right and I'm not in
the rocking H Hall of Fame
wait are you serious you know what I
wouldn't be in it now if they gave me a
million dollar are you serious I'm not
kidding you I was about to say something
else yes I was about to say I'm not yeah
right if you ever change your mind I'm
never going to if you okay I get I have
things in my just go you know what
themselves yeah
that is brand new information for me I'm
just saying if you ever happen to just
just say one other thing okay I changed
music forever with believe you really
did that song you know it's so funny so
let me say one thing I feel like d play
Christmas song let me say one tag it
okay no but I feel like that's what like
how massive and in pop culture and
everything and how it hit and impacted
the pop culture Community how believed
it I feel like that's the same Vibe as
DJ play a Christmas song it's that same
Vibe it's no one has that sound I almost
think if somebody sent me that song for
my Christmas record I was like I don't
know if I could pull this off I don't
know if this is me like it's so you the
sound is so share it's so
incredible I love it so much I kind of
feel like it's the same thing like the
same impact the same impact that that's
so anyway I could talk about you forever
do you get I have to ask though do you I
heard that you get nervous still on
stage do you get nervous are you kidding
me you do oh yeah but you're share
doesn't make any difference I'm only
Kelly what you what are you doing are
you're share be good be happy be excited
don't be scared I know but you shouldn't
be you should just walk around and just
say you're welcome no
but especially around the hall of fame
you're welcome yeah you're welcome you
inspired so many people that are in the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame this is so
I'm not going to let it go sure our
incredible Christmas album is called
share Christmas it's out now so we
talked about it wait a minute what a
great audience you have what is this
well it's you oh I
do I do have great audiences but I will
say you have an impact thank you yeah
hall of fame um so you talked about it a
little a little bit now but you to you
know you you didn't make a Christmas
record till now but what I want to know
is like you worked with your boyfriend
on it so that's do you like working with
significant others on Pro that can that
can go sour well I mean I did with son
and and um but no but this is this was a
little bit different because Alexander
and taigo were in Dubai yeah Michael bé
was in Argentina Cindy was in New York
no Cindy was in New Jersey Darlene was
in New York so all the people that
everybody they were all scattered all
over the world yeah did I leave somebody
out I
probably damn it but I mean I didn't I
didn't I've never had anybody on an
album I didn't start out to do this yeah
and I mean when I I talked to sin and I
went sin I I'm going to I think think
I'm going to make a Christmas Al I don't
know but will you do something on it oh
yeah yeah sure call me later and then I
did I did What Christmas Means to Me
yeah and then I thought yeah no no I
need Stevie so I called Stevie and I was
like I really was Jen is a video of me
because I was just I just needed him so
badly and I just couldn't bear you were
nervous about calling artists to do
things with you yes this is a do you do
you have miror in your
house do you are you aware of your star
and how you shine but you are who you
are this is who I am okay but I need to
let you know that anyone you call is
going to be like I
yes like you're unaware wait wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
Stevie Wonder is not everybody okay
neither are you no well all right well
that's not important right now but um so
then I get on the phone Stevie hi it's
me and he goes oh what's up and I said
I've done your
song and there are parts of it I cannot
get and I've tried and I've tried but
they're not me they're you so I need you
to come and do it what a beautiful way
to act right and so um then I was still
nervous like after he said yes I don't
think I heard it and I just kept selling
it and then and then finally he said at
the end he said share share what wait
hold and I went yeah and he said do you
want me to play my Harmon Monica and was
like oh yes God thank you so much you
want to know why cuz you're share I know
okay but we're going to get it through
what the hell but let wait but then let
me tell you what happened so we hang up
the phone and I go running around my
bedroom I jump up and down on my bed
going Stevie Wonder's gonna be on my
album it's like she's completely unaware
I love that you I I still I love that I
get excited like that too I'm inspired
by artists I love collaborating I do
that too but I just love how
unaware you are of you it's pretty great
yeah in ways I am but in other ways we
just found out right no but in ways I am
but in other ways I'm just not because
you know you you are yourself from like
I've been Shar since I was five just
people didn't know it you know yeah yeah
my mom knew it but but people didn't
know it cuz I was really bizarre I mean
I had dyslexia I still have it but I had
when I was young and so um my teachers
didn't think I was stupid they thought I
didn't apply myself or didn't care or
whatever they had no idea I was learning
everything through listening to them so
one time I got F on my um on my math
test so I came home and I was like not
crying but I was very very upset and I
said Mom I can't even see numbers when I
look at them I don't I can't see them I
know that I'm like I just can't I don't
understand them and she said it's okay
honey when you grow up you're going to
have someone to do math for
you I love your mother no can I tell you
this I'm so thankful that you're open
about that because I actually found that
out and my daughter's dyslexic and like
I I went home last night and we have
dance parties all the time at our house
and the dance party we have now like my
kids know your song so well DJ play
Christmas song that's all we've been
doing in our living room and anyway um I
said hey you know cuz she just found out
she has to have tutoring again or
whatever she was very upset about it and
so anyway when I told her I said hey you
know what I go the girl who sings a song
we've been dancing to almost every night
I was like she's dyslexic I was like and
she's she's better than the Rock and
Roll Hall of
Fame and I'm telling you I'm telling you
it made her feel so powerful that
because I was like you don't see it as a
superpower but it is you just see things
differently that's all most people see
it one way you see it differently but
having people like you who are so
massively popular and people love you
and adore you and you're so successful
and you know you have this amazing life
having kids that have that to look up to
is so cool that you're open about it cuz
I'm not distic so she gets very you know
very sad about it no it's it's really
difficult because you feel that you well
you just feel that you're stupid and and
and there was no name for it when I was
little there was just nothing there was
nothing but um the thing I couldn't do
that I learned how to do Sunny helped me
I couldn't read Because in those days
you had to read in every class you had
to read so many chapters I just couldn't
do it well even with math the problem is
usually it's in word form like hey do
the and then you have to that would
confuse her no yeah well it just it's
confusing as hell all those things you
know and then and then Sunny gave me
when he and I got together because I
said you know I want to read but and I
can read but I just can't do it quickly
at all except I can memorize a script
after one time so go figure yeah but so
he gave me a book called The Saron blade
and I read it and I was like this is
heaven this is just heaven when you find
a book that you really love and then I
just started reading everything I he and
I got in a fight because I was reading
Mario puza you know the Godfather in the
bathroom share go to bed I will be there
in a minute reading this is a good book
yeah oh I love books like that when you
get in when you so do you think you're
going to act again like do any because I
we love you acting as
well we love you
acting well there's two scripts that I'm
doing or I don't know that I'm doing but
I'm thinking about doing them you should
think more about saying Mama Mia three
Mama Mia three I love it yes I love
that I loved when I saw you in that one
I was like wait what is this like it was
Merill and Sher colliding it was it was
awesome for me cuz I'm a huge fan of
both well I love you so much and I know
that you are working your tail off with
promo right now so thank you for
stopping by I'm so happy I'm here this
time of person I'm such a fan I love you
so much everybody give it off the
sh our album is called share Christmas
it's out now you've got to check it
[Music]
out
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home